i briefed the leaders on the
negotiations with the united kingdom
positions remain a part on fundamental
issues
on the level playing field we have
repeatedly
made clear to our uk partners that the
principle of
fair competition is a preconditioned
to privileged access to the eu market
it is the largest single market in the
world
and it is only fair that competitors to
our
own enterprises face the same conditions
on our own market but this is
not to say that we would require the uk
to follow us every time we decide to
raise our level of ambition
for example in the environmental field
they would remain free sovereign
if you wish to decide what they want to
do we would simply adapt
the conditions for access to our market
accordingly
the decision of the united kingdom and
this would apply
vice versa on fisheries
here also we continue to have a gap we
have not yet found the solutions to
bridge our differences
we understand that the uk aspires to
control
its waters the uk must on the other hand
understand the legitimate
expectations of eu fishing fleets
built on decades and sometimes centuries
of access
on these and other points our
negotiators are working
we will decide on sunday
whether we have the conditions for an
agreement or not
in the meantime the commission has
proposed four targeted
contingency measures today they provide
a short-term fix to ensure basic
connectivity
in-air and road transport for six months
and we are also proposing to the uk
to ensure reciprocal access to each
other's waters
for next year one way or the other
in less than three weeks it will be new
beginnings for old friends
thank you